foreign
[Music]
idiot is a very vague opaque arm group
and they've been active for three
decades
[Music]
we now see that there are two factions
within adf one the biggest faction that
has claimed or swore allegiance to isis
and another smaller faction that still
uh strives for the older idea of
fighting with 70 and overthrowing them
with 70 government but the biggest
faction is the one that's currently
being targeted
[Music]
what we've seen in the past with adf is
that there's always a bit of a cycle adf
is active they attack the population
we've now seen the recent attacks in
kampala and uganda itself and then
there's often a step up in military
operations by the congolese afterwards
we often see retaliation by the adf on
the congolese population so it's a bit
of a cyclical violence
we've seen connections between adf
active in eastern drc and the rebel
movements active in northern mozambique
so we see rwanda actually fighting
rebels in northern mozambique and uganda
now targeting adf also linked to isis in
eastern drc but these two groups there
are also connections between the two so
we've seen these transnational networks
emerging also
being provided financial assistance by
isis members in kenya nairobi so it's
definitely a network that's on the rise
in the region
you